نعم ، نحن نتعلم تفاصيل جديدة حول
ما حدث مما أدى إلى
هروب النزيل كيسي وايت وضابطة الإصلاحيات
فيكي وايت ، فيديو جديد صدر
عن فيكي وايت داخل فندق نزل عالي الجودة
ليس بعيدًا عن هنا في محكمة المقاطعة
حيث يُزعم أنها بقيت فيها
الخميس في الليلة التي سبقت الهروب
الأسبوع الماضي فقط ، ألقينا أيضًا نظرة
داخل سيارة الدورية التي استخدمتها
لنقل النزيل الأبيض كيسي خارج
مركز الاحتجاز ، وتذكر أنه كانت هناك
خطة مفادها أنهم كانوا ذاهبون إلى
تقييم الصحة العقلية هنا في
محكمة المقاطعة ونعلم الآن أن
هذا لم يحدث أبدًا ، ولم
يتم تحديد موعد لجلسات استماع داخل أن
محققو سيارة الدورية وجدوا
مفاتيح سجنها في الراديو الخاص بها وأشياء أخرى ، ثم
تم التخلي عن سيارة الدورية تلك في
مركز تجاري ومن المفترض أنهم دخلوا
في سيارة برتقالية  حافة
وأن سيارة الدفع الرباعي تم العثور عليها في
منتصف الطريق في ويليامسون تينيسي على
بعد حوالي ساعتين شمال هنا ،
يعتقد الشريف أن ذلك وا  ليس جزءًا من
خطتهم ، فهو يعتقد أن السيارة الرياضية متعددة الاستخدامات تعطلت
وتداخلت مع خطة الهروب هذه ،
لكن كان لديهم بالفعل بداية
قوية ، ونعلم أيضًا أن فيكي وايت استحوذت على
حوالي 90 ألف دولار من حساباتها المصرفية
أثناء هروبها
للمساعدة في هذا الهروب الذي يأتي جميعًا
من مكتب العمدة الآن ،
كل هذا يحدث لأن العمدة يقول إن
كايسي وايت وفيكي وايت التقيا في
مركز احتجاز مقاطعة لودرديل
خلال اتهامات الاتهام أثناء
محاكمته بتهم القتل العمد
في وفاة كوني ريدجواي و
تحدثنا إلى ابن كوني ريدجواي
أوستن ويليامز ، إليك نداءه لكايسي
وايت ،
يرجى تسليم نفسك في أقرب وقت
ممكن ، أعني أنني أعلم
أنك اعترفت بقتل والدتي
ومن المحتمل
أنك بريء وإذا  أنت بريء ،
دعنا نكتشف أنك تعرف ما إذا كنت
بريئًا ، فأنا على ما يرام مع ذلك ، لا أريد
أن يعاقب أي شخص بريء على
شيء لم يفعله سوى التنوير القائل  سلم
نفسك في
حاكم ألاباما كاي إيفي مضيفة خمسة
آلاف دولار كمكافأة لكل من
كيسي وايت وفيكي وايت ، ورفعت تلك
المكافأة الإجمالية لكليهما إلى 25
ألف دولار